my goodness me this place is gorgeous
who built it
no seriously bare hands you are kidding
me
Wow yeah it's all family business we're
all together
Wow and recently my oldest brother Zach
took over the restaurant so Zach's the
restaurant manager bass mum dad around
so I'd love to meet them I'll follow you
Wow look at those beauties at there's a
vegetarian nightmare oh yeah let's fish
everywhere well this is definitely a
family-run business right yes Gordon how
are you the gentle giants with the Midas
touch by looks of things
congratulations place is gorgeous thank
you thank you I'm at Disney World it
really I did build it Wow just had a
vision in my mind and we put things up
took them down until it looked right and
you live on the property I did we have a
cabin right across the way just here
yeah third time will you build out as
well I did where was the conversation
you both had when you decided to go
ahead and build it we found this old
beat-up buildings there was a for sale
sign on the back side of it so we've
made a deal and here we are started
building what was the dream duty what
was the ambition well you know we just
love love the beautiful river we just
saw it boom you know because of the
beauty it's really one of the most
beautiful spots at night home are people
just loved it so there was like a
two-hour wait every night how long ago
was that that was our first two years
Wow I don't first two years that's a
long time ago so he got off to a great
stuff what happened then we had another
shift and then people got mad because we
changed the menu after that we had a
tragedy after the tragedy my parents
just kind of checked out it was a really
hard time for my family and I think it
showed in the lodge you know they
couldn't put their whole heart into it
because their heart was broken so are
you in love with it as much today as you
were ten years ago I'm very proud of it
and I love it but I'm really tired
right we've been here a long time you
know our goal is to have the best
restaurant in the area and
and then 100 miles around but through
the years we've just lost interest in
that and he's really tired you know he
doesn't want to work that hard anymore
what so you're the best manager yes and
where did you train I worked in a few
really nice places when I was living in
San Diego that was where I probably
write learned the most OC went away and
then came back I've been gone for about
nine years yeah right okay only at the
room unpacked
is that why don't you show me to the
room yes No
what's that smell of lemon I'm not sure
that smell of lemon
I mean why nurse would you need air
freshener in here is such beautiful woof
yeah the smell in here is crazy now let
me quickly up the window I guess the
back your throat right yeah somebody to
make up the best they are made I've seen
dog baskets better hold away they put in
about five years ago
bloody hell seriously yeah there's
definitely old blood I don't think so
sure it's a stain anyway Wow
okay so I'll be down couple minutes or a
bite to eat
sounds great yeah would you recommend
she does the rainbow trout here what's
the name my name is Jeannie okay great
thanks the update thanks act wow the
view is breathtaking but the color is
depressing I mean honestly everything's
dark and grey and dingy and the pillows
look at those how uninviting but the dog
sat on it for the last ten years really
do smell what is that it's like a piece
of candy stuck on the pillow just oh
it's almost like they've fallen out of
love for this place
and look at that Oh big dirty stain